bonsoir et bienvenue sur TVfil 78
jusqu'au 1er janvier la rédaction vous
propose une série d'éditions spéciales
pour revenir sur les événements qui ont
marqué 2012 et aussi parler de ceux qui
vont rythmer 2013 5 émissions à
découvrir pour autant de thématiques
politique économie sport et ce soir
environnement mais aussi in inovation
bonsoir Valérie oribo c'est avec nous
avec vous que nous parlerons
environnement et innovation donc trois
invités pour nous accompagner durant la
prochaine demi-heure oui le tout premier
sera Philippe Heurtevent mare
d'aotuteuil le roi membre du collectif
svon les Yvelines un collectif
d'agriculteurs en colère et inquiet pour
leur avenir et puis ensuite enfin tout
d'abord la chronique innovation avec
Valérie Barbet Massin de Renault et
David le guide de ADM concept pour
évoquer l'autopartage et le concept
twezy way sur 51 en Yveline parler de la
tweezy ce véhicule électrique dont on a
beaucoup parl en 2012 on va aussi
forcément parler en 2013 et on en parle
ce soir dans cette édition du 78 bonsoir
à tous les deux on vous entendra dans un
instant avant de revenir sur cette Ty
justement on va parler des abeilles
Valérie les abeilles on sait qu'elles
sont importantes forcément si les
abeilles venaient à disparaître
l'humanité aussi on le sait c'est une
phrase entendue mais elles sont choyées
à 50 ans neline et tout à fait puisque
trappe a été l'une des communes
initiatrices hein de de l'installation
d'un rucher en fait les villes de saint
en Eveline souhaite installer des ruches
pour rapprocher les populations de
l'environnement et la ville de La
Verrière n'a pas résister également à
installer son rucher c'était en
septembre
dernier après la communauté
d'agglomération en avril le weekend
dernier c'était autour de la verrière
d'inaugurer son rucher dans le cadre de
l'opération nationale abeille sentinelle
de l'environnement un message politique
et citoyens selon Alain aage maire de la
commune s'intéresser de s'interroger sur
les conditions de la odiversité sur
notre territoire national et régional et
local et donc on sait qu'aujourd'hui
cette biodiversité est en danger qu'il y
a des des risques de voir tous les
phénomènes naturels perturbés par la
pollution les pesticides conséquence
grave pour l'environnement la
disparition des abeilles depuis
plusieurs années et sans ces insectes
pollinisateurs on peut dire adieu à
notre agriculture selon l'Union
nationale de l'apiculture française
grâce à leur action les abeilles génère
chaque année un chiffre d'affaires
d'environ 3 milliards d'euros pour plus
de 30 % de ce qu'on consomme provient du
rôle des abeilles par la polonisation
parmi la population l'abeille maintenant
les enjeux que représent l'abeille sont
vraiment perçus par la population et les
politiques se disent qu'effectivement il
faut prendre des décisions pour arriver
à sauvegarder les abeilles parce qu'on
est passé d'un taux de mortalité qui é
environ 5 % il y a encore 15 ou 20 ans à
un taux de mortalité de plus de 30 % par
an l'installation des R verrière roi
sera complété par des prairies fleuries
afin que les abeilles puissent butiner
des actions pédagogiques seront
organisées avec les écoles de la ville
et pour les gourmands sachez que le miel
sera récolté à l'occasion des apidaises
au mois de juin prochaine inauguration
de Ruchet sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin au printemps il s'agira
cette fois de la ville de
Montini le 78 édition spéciale fin
d'année deux invités nous accompagnent
donc au début de cette C édition pour
parler de la tzy CE quadricycle
développé par Renault absolument wilfri
nous allons revenir sur le concept
twezyway instauré à c-quentin en yeline
lancé depuis juin 2012 avec une période
de de test de 3 mois Valérie Barb Massin
de chez renud vous êtes avec nous pour
en parler bonjour Merci d'être sur ce
plateau avec également David le guide de
amdm concept qui qui a largement
participer à l'installation de de ce de
cet autopartage et donc sur quelle ville
sont instau
aujourd'hui les tezyway alors tezyway
est la première expérimentation pour
Renault à 5 en Eveline grâce à un
partenariat qui a déjà été initié il y a
à peu près 2 ans et nous serons amenés
nous travaillons déjà sur les prochains
projet dans des villes potentiellement
en France mais également en Europe
d'accord donc aujourd'hui c'est voisins
c'est Montini alors la zone
effectivement du service tewe tel qu'il
est à 550 iveline c'est voisin breteneux
montinil breteneux aiguille en cours et
puis un petit peu de trap pour inclure
la la gare donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
la zone de service où on peut trouver
les véhicules tway pour l'autopartage
d'accord est-ce que on peut revenir sur
du coup ce ce concept d'autopartage
instauré en juin dernier donc en fait ce
sont 50 véhicules 50 twy qui sont
installés sur le terrain sur n'importe
où on va dire de façon très très libre
et les clients
abonnés vont pouvoir identifier ses
véhicules savoir où il se trouvent pour
pour les utiliser soit sur un site
internet soit grâce à une application
smartphone ou soit directement dans la
rue et pouvoir monter dedans on va dire
l'utiliser pour des trajets courts
ponctuels pratiqu et ensuite conduire
jusqu'où ils voudront et le la laisser
là où ils le voudront c'est vraiment la
totale liberté il y a pas aller dans les
stations aller sur des bornes c'est le
gros avantage et Renault réaliser une
étude justement après 4 mois et demi un
petit peu de de test pour voir comment
ça fonctionnait si les résultats étaient
bon étude qui étaaient rendu publique 92
% des personnes interrogées qui font
part de leur plaisir à utiliser ce
service surtout pour les petits trajets
poste banque boulangerie puisque
effectivement il y a pas de souci de
parking on peut laisser le véhicule où
on veut les résultats sont sont bons
donc sur C sur les les premiers mois
d'utilisation sur ex en fait on a eu un
retour extrêmement positif du niveau de
satisfaction et et de l'engouement de
ces clients test testeurs puisqueen fait
nous avons eu 200 clients testeurs entre
juin et septembre septembre étant
effectivement la date à laquelle le
service a été ouvert au grand public et
c'est été très très en encourageant
alors il savaiit effectivement ces
clients testeur qu'il pouvait y avoir
éventuellement des petits adaptations à
faire on les avait je dirais entamé
notre collaboration avec eux pour cela
et le retour a été de leur part très
positif et en plus on a pratiquement
même plus que 2 ti3 de ces client
testeur qui se sont réabonnés qui ont
continué la route teway malgré
l'augmentation des tarifs qui sont plus
des tarifs grand public maintenant que
tarif testeur alors les tarifs justement
quels sont-ils alors vous avez pour vous
abonner pour être client il faut donc
acheter un badge qui le vaut 15 € une
fois pour toute et surtout après vous
êtes facturé à la minute donc c'est 29
centimes la minute quand vous conduisez
et puis 10 centimes d'euros la minute
quand la voiture est toujours gardé pour
vous réservé pour vous et que vous
faites une course et ADM concept a
participé à la mise en place un petit
peu de ce service on va en parler dans
un instant pour bien rituer comment
fonctionne cet autopartage on va
redécouvrir un reportage réalisé par la
rédaction diffusé le 18 septembre
dernier
à peine ouvert qu'il font la queue
devant la porte la T en autopartage
arrive sur la communauté d'agglomération
de 50 ans en evel et séduit déjà les
futurs utilisateurs j'ai beaucoup d'amis
qui sont dans dans la ville mais pas
très proche de chez moi ça me
permettrait d'aller voir d'aller les
voir plus rapidement c'est pas trop cher
financièrement parlant et voilà pour 29
centimes par minute c'est pratique si on
fait qu'un trajet 2 3
minutes au lie de prendre le bus et P
1,90 € pour réserver votre twezy
rendez-vous sur Internet ou sur votre
smartphone pour vérifier la
disponibilité et le taux de charge des
véhicules l'autre façon plus direct
cette fois vous rendre sur une zone de
garage tezy sur les communes de
guillencour Montini voisin Bretonneux et
trappe et muni de votre badge débloquer
la voiture pas d'abonnement seulement
des frais d'adhésion de 15 € pour
obtenir votre pass tzy on ne paye que
lors de
l'utilisation lorsque je roule là je
suis à 29 centimes la minute plafonné à
11 90 de l'heure si je suis en arrêt
temporaire comme là c'est-à-dire que
personne d'autre que moi ne peut
l'utiliser mais il est en stationnement
à ce moment-là je suis à 10 centimes la
minute et puis en plus si je veux le
réserver j'ai un forfait réservation de
1 € pour 15 minutes de réservation les 5
premières minutes sont gratuites après
le passage du badge sur le Code Bar et
pour ce service d'autopartage il faut
être titulaire d'un permis voiture
depuis plus de 2
ans alors David le guide vous êtes
directeur financier chez ADM concept qui
fut l'un des partenaires de Renault pour
pour instaurer la tweeyway quel a été
votre rôle teway est un projet avec un
nouveau concept de véhicule un nouveau
concept d'utilisation et il y a les
contraintes à ce ces solution et nous a
demandé d'intégrer ses contraintes dans
ce véhicule donc autrement dit nous
avons dû faire des études des prototypes
intégrer tout ça de façon en préparant
une solution industrielle et dans des
dél records bien sûr avec derrière bah
une solution qui a été mise en place en
temps et en heure pour Renault sur ce
projet alors c'était instaé installer
des équipements c'est ça oui ça touche
en fait de de l'électronique de la
plasturgie ça touche de la mécanique et
du montage démontages vous avez tout un
tas de de de chaînes de valeur qui
doivent être pensé et ensuite exécuté
d'accord alors je rappelle quand même
que ADM concept qui est une entreprise
de montiné le Bretonneux a été primé au
concours l'épine en 2011 pour son kit
adaptant une un VO une voiture
électrique à l'autopartage tout à fait
en fait nous avons plusieurs nominations
qui ont eu lieu depuis 2 3 ans nous
avons fait de très gros efforts de RD
sur la partie électrique et notamment
autopartage parce que c'est une version
de d'utilisation de du véhicule
électrique auquel nous croyons beaucoup
et nous positionnons aujourd'hui en
leadership sur ce marché avec
l'intégration en fait de toutes types de
voiture et de tout types d'usage et la
twe est un usage il y en aura d'autres
on en parlait en apparté tout à l'heure
avec le B2B avec les entreprises ise il
y a tout un tas d'applications qui sont
en train de se créer en fait il faut
utiliser le système une fois pour
l'adopter vous ne vous êtes dans un
nouveau monde vous avez un usage une
consommation avec un vrai partenaire qui
vous met à disposition un véhicule pour
vos petits trajets quotidiens ou tout un
tas de de solutions nous nous sommes là
pour que l'intégration soit parfaitement
exécutée telle qu'elle a été demandée
d'accord alors quel bilan peut-on tirer
aujourd'hui après ces quelques mois de
d'utilisation en
autopartage alors c'est un bilan positif
dans la mesure où effectivement
l'intérêt et surtout le faire connaître
de ce style nouveau innovant de
service de par les retours que nous
avons c'est vraiment une réussite de ce
pointl point de vuel et en fait je pense
qu'il faut encore et toujours expliquer
promouvoir et surtout écouter ce que les
clients nous disent parce que ne
connaissant pas forcément ce type de
mobilité ceux qui goûtent ceux qui
l'utilisent se rendent compte de toutes
les possibilités que ça peut représenter
pour eux et on parlait également de par
le fait que il y a des solutions
techniques innovantes l'utilisation du
smartphone pour qu'un client puisse
réserver l'identification sur une carte
dynamique tout ça c'est des un
accompagnement qui peuv qui peut
permettre à l'évolution de ce type de
service qui je pense est vraiment à son
démarrage d'accord donc aujourd'hui
Saint-Quentin est la vitrine de de ce
concept des projets pour
2013 tout à fait alors euh nous pouvons
pas encore vous donner des éléments très
concrets mais il y en a quand même un en
B2B en donc promouvoir twezyway auprès
des entreprises nous allons démarrer
cours en
décembre une flotte en fait de 20
véhicules au CEA de Grenoble qui
souhaitaent proposer un système propre
un système écologique à ses employés
pour pouvoir faire des mouvements
intérieurs à l'intérieur de leur site
entre une usine et les différents
bâtiments et donc ça ça démarre c'est
une deuxième expérimentation juste une
dernière question 8000 twe qui ont été
rappelé ça c'était au mois de de
novembre comment ça s'est passé pour les
véhicules en autopartage Ren a rappelé
certains véhicules pour un problème de
de frein alors pour nous tway ça s'est
extrêmement bien passé dans la mesure où
nos véhicules reviennent
systématiquement au garage très très
très régulièrement donc on avait sous la
main que pour recharger les batteries
exactement ils reviennent pour recharger
les batteries donc les checks et les
vérifications blocage du parc de voit
parce que en fait ça a été fait
instantanément donc ça c'était un autre
avantage par exemple de ce que l'artage
pe appor au clients voilà et puis si
vous avez une Ty vous n'aviez pas
entendu parler de ce rappel de véhicule
c'est l'occasion d'une petite piqûure de
rappel justement vous pouvez rentrer en
contact avec Renault il a une petite
vérification effectuée sur sur le
véhicule voilà 8000 véhicules en Europe
qui ont été rappelés c'était en novembre
dernier merci à tous les deux d'être
venu donc sur ce plateau nous parler de
ce concept d'autopartage de la tey on en
a beaucoup parlé en 2012 on devrait en
parler aussi en 2013 Valérie on va
poursuivre cette page spéciale cette
édition spéciale du 78 on va parler à
présent de l'environnement et pour faire
la transition entre innovation et
environnement quoi de mieux qu'un sujet
véhicule électrique le point sur le
marché de l'électrique c'était le 1er
octobre dernier à l'occasion du Salon de
l'automobile pour ce Mondial de l'OTO
2012 de Paris encore une fois les 270
marques présentes rivalisent
d'ingéniosité dans le domaine de
l'électrique et de l'hybride tour
d'horizon des constructeurs installés
dans les ivelines on a une offre la
Peugeot la lion voiture tout électrique
mais une voiture tout électrique encore
aujourd'hui inévitablement présente de
réelles contraintes d'autonomie donc une
voiture électrique et on pense nous pour
encore quelques années quand même sera
forcément concentrée à une un usage
quasi strictement urbain on croit
beaucoup plus dans la technologie de
l'hybride diesel on va pouvoir proposer
des voitures comme une 3008 hybride 4 et
bien qui fait 200 chevaux qui propose
quatre roues motrices et qui est
homologué à environ 4 L5 de diesel au
sang la marque française porte aussi un
intérêt tout particulier au pays en voie
de développement elle présente cette
année une berline 301 réservée au marché
asiatique ruses et africain direction le
stand de BMW le constructeur allemand
présente cette année sa nouvelle marque
écologique explication avec le
responsable
France vous avez sous les yeux les BMW
i8 Concept et i3 Concept qui sont à 80 %
à peu près identiques à ce que seront
les modèle de série dans un an ces
voitures sont faites pour
l'électromobilité avec des matériaux
ultra léger comme la fibre de carbone ou
l'aluminium et en plus totalement
responsable de l'environnement puisquon
utilise beaucoup de matériaux
recyclés sur ces deux voitures les
premiers véhicules seront commercialisés
fin 2013 chez Ford c'est une grande
première le constructeur américain
s'apprête à commercialiser deux
véhicules électriques et hybrid en
France ces modèles étaient pour
l'instant uniquement disponibles aux
États-Unis où le marché de l'électrique
et de l'hybride représente 5 % du
secteur
automobile on présente une Focus 100 %
électrique donc là vous n'avez pas de
moteur thermique vous avez euh 150 km
d'autonomie c'est parfait pour un usage
urbain ou péri urbain ou pour des usages
professionnels et à côté on présente une
Mondeo hybride qui elle va être parfaite
pour voyager parce que vous aurez une
hybridation c'est l'association d'un
moteur électrique et d'un moteur
thermique qui vous permet en ville de
baisser considérablement les émissions
et les consommations mais malgré tout
d'avoir beaucoup d'autonomie pour
voyager quand vous voulait voyager loin
et en
famille on pense que les moteurs
thermiques ont encore des progrès à
faire et not notamment chez nous nous
avons développé un moteur bicylindre qui
s'appelle le twinir nous travaillons
également sur des carburants alternatifs
faut savoir que Fiat est leader en
Europe sur le GNV le méthane donc des
c'est un carburant encore plus propre
que les GPL et nous avons aussi une
large gamme de véhicules GPL la 500
électrique sera mise sur le marché
américain l'année prochaine l'Europe
devra encore attendre on termine avec
l'umé néo une PME desvelin spécialisée
dans le véhicule électrique l'électrique
c'est l'énergie du futur pour la ville
pas pour les grandes distances c'est
évident on a un problème de Capacité de
batterie mais pour la ville c'est c'est
vraiment l'énergie du futur parce que
pas de pollution pas de bruit facilité
de pas de pompe à essence aussi dans la
ville faut y penser c'est quand même pas
si facile que ça les progrès techniques
auront lieu d'abord sur le poids du
véhicule qui qui baisse tout le temps et
aussi sur l'autonomie grâce à de
meilleures batterie mais là le saut
technologique sera fait plutôt dans 3 4
ans ou voir un peu plus
sans oublier la tzie de chez Renault le
véhicule électrique en autopartage pour
l'instant exclusivement sur le
territoire
cinquantinois le 78 édition spéciale fin
d'année se poursuit nous parlons
innovation environnement également à
présent sur ce plateau de nouveaux
invités vont nous rejoindre ils sont
membres du collectif sauvons les
Yvelines des agriculteurs qui sont en
colère le territoire agricole se réduit
en Île-de-France et dans le département
des ivelines pour l'instant c'est vous
qui avez la parole que peut-on vous
souhaiter pour 2013 micro trottoir on
vous écoute je sais pas bonne question
réussir les concours réussir le partiel
avoir un bon dossier pour entrer dans
une belle école de commerce un peu plus
de travail pour les gens hein et un peu
plus d'humanité aussi ah là là si c'est
personnel Ce serait pour ma maman qui
est très malade et si c'est pas
personnel c'est pour la conjoncture
économique que ça redémarre les gens ils
savent même pas se dire bonjour ils se
connaissent même pas dans les mêmes
immeuble et puis quand il arrive la fin
de
l'année on a les gens qui sont dehors
ils ont froid ceux qui dont pas le
boulot ils ont pas un rang et et on fait
des vœux non on fait pas des vœux il
faut être poli toute l'année et gentil
toute l'année c'est ça le vœux surtout
que les jeunes ils trouvent du boulot ça
me ferait bien plaisir pour eux parce
que ça pas l'air facile une superbe
santé c'est
tout une dizaine de minutes encore à
passer ensemble lors de cette édition du
78 avec le collectif sauvons les
ivelines bonsoir à vous deux tout
d'abord pH pertevant vous êtes maire
d'uteuil le roi président du collectif
sauvon Les ivelines et Dominique Duval
vous êtes secrétaire général de ce
collectif qui regroupe notamment des
élus des agriculteurs des gens du
terrain on va parler de vos inquiétudes
puisque le territoire agricole se réduit
dans le département des ivelines il est
malgré tout encore important Valéri oui
Wilfried pour 70 % le territoire
yvelinois est couvert par l'agriculture
et la forêt selon les chiffres de la
chambre de l'agriculture en 2000 on
recensait 1270 exploitations agricoles
deux exploitation sur 5 aurait disparu
en 12 ans pour autant la taille moyenne
de ces exploitations a quasiment doublé
en 20 ans passant de 39 hectares en
1979 à 71 hectares en 2000 et l'activité
principale sont les céréales alors
Philippe hortevant je me tourne vers
vous bonjour Quel quel bilan tirez-vous
de cette année 2012 qui a été riche en
protestation et en manifestation et
pourquoi c'est pas la première année
hein c'est notre action a dém Maré déjà
depuis 2006 donc pourquoi parce que nous
souhaitons rester vigilant sur la
protection justement de cette terr
agricole aujourd'hui il faut savoir
qu'il y a environ l'équivalent d'un
département qui disparaît en France tous
les 7 ans donc ça veut dire que tous les
7 ans on on urbanise des terres
agricoles et ces terres-l ne reviendront
jamais à l'agriculture parce que c'est
un processus irréversible c'est soit des
grandes surfaces soit des autoroutes
soit des de de l'urbanisation donc
aujourd'hui notre volonté c'est dans le
cadre de ce collectif qui regroupe à la
fois des élus des agriculteurs des
associations de protection de
l'environnement et ça c'est important
parce que le tissu associatif dans les
ivelines est quand même très important
et très efficace très actif et donc nous
souhaitons mettre en place une véritable
politique de densification des centres
de nos communes de manière à avoir des
surfaces de jardin beaucoup plus
modestes
faut savoir que par exemple à grorouvre
le le le le terrain est de 5000 m² la
parcelle pour construire je sais pas si
vous rendez compte pour une maison donc
aujourd'hui dans le cadre des la mise en
place des pélus tous les maires dans le
cadre du Grenel de l'environnement 2 ont
l'obligation de densifier les centres
pour justement préserver les terres
agricoles pour dire stop au tout
béton non c'est pas vraiment ça puisque
on peut mettre en place toutes les
nouvelles
technologies de d'urbanisation avec
notamment l'arrivée du bois dans les
constructions en bois donc nous sommes
tout à fait d'accord pour la mise en
place de toutes ces nouvelles
technologie qui vont d'ailleurs créer
des emplois dans dans les ivelines mais
nous ce que nous voulons c'est avoir une
consommation minimum des terres
agricoles pour justement préserver
l'avenir et les générations à venir
parce que malheureusement la plupart des
gens ne raisonne que au bout de leur
jardin ou au bout de leur vie mais non
il nous faut raisonner plus loin
maintenant il faut env envisager
l'avenir pour les années 50 dans 2050
2100 donc il faut penser à ces gens-là
votre collectif existe depuis 2006 vous
disiez beaucoup de mobilisation de
manifestations aussi en 2012 au mois de
novembre dernier vous avez été reçu
également en préfecture est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'être entendu et que
les choses avancent et que finalement
bah vous réussissez à préserver ces
terres agricoles alors il faut savoir
que
effectivement le
l'action reste le seul levier pour se
faire entendre est-ce qu'elle fonctionne
cette action et et ce levier et ce
levier fonctionne encore nous avons été
cordialement reçu par monsieur le préfet
Michel Joe donc qui euh a vraiment eu
une écoute particulière à l'égard des
des agriculteurs et du collectif sauvant
les ivelines il nous a proposé donc une
réunion de travail à nouveau qui a eu
lieu le 22 novembre dernier où nous
avons pu avec lui abord et ses services
aborder un certain nombre de de
questions qui engagent l'avenir des
ivelines NOTAM notamment on a pu parler
du fameux projet de d'installation du
PSG dans les
ivelines il y a plusieurs sites qui sont
retenus pour l'installation du futur
cand deséloges soit il restera sur place
à Saint-Germain au lait soit
éventuellement à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline si vous nous avez suivi nous en
avons parlé on parle également de
poissis et là ce serait sur des terres
agricoles et les agriculteurs ne sont
pas
contents les agriculteurs et nous-même
on a on a la même démarche on s'est
mobilisé aussi contre le circuit de
Formule 1 ça c'est c'est exactement
c'est la réserve d'eau en plus pour le
circuit de Formule 1 c'était sur la
réserve d'eau pour pour les générations
à venir je veux dire on n pas le droit
de de de de de de mettre en place des
projets aussi
pharaomnique sans penser effectivement
aux conséquences en qui si existe dans
les evelines existe aussi à plus grande
échelle dans toute la
France ce type de
problématique la la la problème le
problème c'est qu'on a voulu la
décentralisation puis en fin de compte
on personne veut la faire je veux dire
faut toujours faire plus le plus grand
plus grand plus grand le plus grand
Paris parce pour être la capitale la
plus grande de Europe ou peut-être la
plus grande du monde mais l'objectif de
la décentralisation et de la
régionalisation c'était pas ça du tout
donc il faut effectivement à l'heure
actuelle avec les moyens de
communication qu'on a
notamment tout ce qui est numérique et
via le l'Internet on peut aujourd'hui
décentraliser facilement et mettre en
place des choses plus loin on n'est pas
obligé de tout mettre à Paris sur les 3
minutes qui nous reste on va se projeter
un peu sur 2013 on va beaucoup parler
Durif forcément en 3 le drift c'est le
schéma d'aménagement régional qui est
voté par la Région Île-de-France la
première mouture a été votée lors d'une
assemblée régionale c'était le 25
octobre dernier il y a plusieurs points
qui vous inquiètent on va en parler avec
vous donc Dominique Duval notamment
cette liaison cet axe entre manth et
Saint-Quentin en yeline qui permettrait
de développer le trafic routier
exactement donc c'est vrai que ce ce
drift 2013 donc j'ai l'occasion de de
pas mal le suivre puisque je suis
également membre du Conseil économique
social et environnemental régional
d'Île-de-France où je siège
et donc c'est vraiment un sujet
d'actualité la version Z 2013 est
rassurante euh puisque à force de faire
remonter notre inquiétudes sur cette
lisomement de 51 Yveline qui en fait
fragmenterait les exploitations
agricoles donc à terme elle ne serait
plus rentable donc elle disparaîtrait et
il y aurait urbanisation donc à force
d'alerter effectivement cette mouture je
vais dire de fin 2012 le la liaison MRE
550 Eveline n'y est plus ni dans les
textes ni sur la carte h mais maintenant
cette mouture elle remonte vers les
départements d'Île-de-France elle
remonte vers les Chambres régionales
d'agriculture elle remonte vers les
chambres de commerce et d'industrie et
nous savons déjà que au niveau du
département des ivelines au niveau du
conseil général des ivelines il y a une
délibération en mars 2012 peut-être
qu'ils vont en faire une autre he c'est
possible mais pour l'instant nous on se
réfère à ce que l'on connaît la
délibération de mars 2012 où il disait
clairement que cette liaison M 51
iveline il la voulait on sait également
que la chambre de comm commerce et
d'industrie des evvelines a très très
envie aussi que cette liaison mais
forcément chacun défend ses intérêts je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable
forcément dévelpp
éconvc mais le développement économique
ne passe pas que par les infrastructures
routières d'accord je pense que on a
quand même évolué maintenant dans la
façon de de faire de l'économie hein et
cet axe là la la logique était de dire
ça relie deux opérations d'intérêt
national donc ça a changé de nom avec le
nouveau enfin on va on va on va passer
donc c'était de relier donc manth 51 en
Eveline
euh nous on voit pas l'intérêt déjà
parce que c'est pas du tout les mêmes
pôles de développement et donc vous
allez continuer à vous mobiliser tout au
long de l'année 2013 on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler sur ce plateau merci à
tous les deux d'être d'être venu à
l'occasion de cette édition spéciale fin
d'année merci Valérie également pour ce
point innovation environnement les
éditions spécial du 78 sur TVfil 78 se
poursuivent jusqu'au 1er janvier elles
sont à retrouver en intégralité sur
notre site internet on se retrouvera le
2 janvier avec toute la rédaction pour
une nouvelle année excellente fin
d'année justement en attendant 2013 sur
TVFI